الامير هاري يكشف عن تعرضه وزوجته لمطارده
شبيهه بمصرع والدته ديانا نصور البابارات
زيتارا دو هاري وميجان ووالدتها بست
سيارات في مدينه نيويورك
[موسيقى]
المطارده استمرت اكثر من ساعتين وشرفت على
التصادم اكثر من مره
الحادثه شبه كارثيه الشهره لا يجب ان تاتي
ابدا على حساب سلامه المرء
المطارده تعيد الى الذاكره مصرع الاميره
ديانا عام
1997 عندما قضت في احد انفاق باريس بعد
مطاردتها من قبل مصورين على دراجات ناريه
الخوف على التخلي عن واجباته الملكيه عام
2020 والانتقال للعيش في كاليفورنيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات